the continuing legal battle over the fbi
raid at former president trump's florida
home on friday the affidavit used by the
fbi to obtain a search warrant was made
public the 38-page document offers the
most detailed description of the
government records many of them
classified that were being stored at
trump's mar-a-lago property the second
half of the affidavit is almost entirely
redacted honoring the justice
department's request to maintain the
investigation's integrity and to protect
the safety of witnesses and law
enforcement personnel
late friday trump's attorneys filed
court papers arguing the newly released
affidavit offers almost no information
about why the search was necessary
robert costa has the latest from west
palm beach florida bob good morning
good morning jeff the fallout continues
today from the release of that redacted
affidavit and it goes across multiple
fronts political legal and national
security 19 days after former president
trump's home was searched
the redacted affidavit reveals that of
the 15 boxes of government records
donald trump brought with him to
mar-a-lago and ultimately returned to
the archives in january 14 had
classified documents some including
sensitive information derived from
government informants critical to u.s
intelligence gathering that is the
linchpin of the entire affidavit we are
talking about materials that could kill
people as well as of course reveal
sources and methods really undermine our
national security in total investigators
found 184 documents with classification
markings including 67 documents marked
as confidential 92 marked as secret and
25 top secret the documents labeled hcs
referring to human confidential sources
stood out to former acting cia director
mike morrell the ones that are most
concerning to me
are the mon are the ones that were
marked hcs
which is a marking that indicates that
information was derived from
cia spies overseas the affidavit
underscores the alarm about the possible
vulnerability of trump's waterfront
property
a secret service source tells cbs news
that it is a private club with
protection but limited background checks
the affidavit goes on to provide a
glimpse into the justice department's
sources
and who might have witnessed potential
criminal activity at mar-a-lago
noting the department spoke to a
significant number of civilian witnesses
in order to protect them from
intimidation or from being publicly
outed the florida federal judge and
federal prosecutors agreed on the
extensive redactions the fbi agent who
wrote the affidavit also said there was
probable cause to believe that evidence
of obstruction will be found at trump's
property
as well as contraband fruits of crime
and other items illegally possessed
trump and his republican allies remain
frustrated with the search and with the
justice department his spokesman saying
the affidavit was overtly political
former trump intelligence official john
ratcliffe spoke to cbs's katherine
herridge the unsealing of this today
isn't going to do much to again tamp
down the the chaos the the confusion
this all comes as former president trump
continues to consider a possible 2024
presidential bid his allies tell cbs
news that this past week has been a
weary one for some of them due to how
this has all played out but they say he
is still determined to consider that
2024 bid jeff
bob the affidavit mentioned obstruction
of justice can you expand on what that
might mean
the former president and his lawyers
have been engaged in a long-running
dialogue with lawyers from the national
archives and now justice department
lawyers about how he handled highly
classified information when he left the
white house in early of 2021 and this
whole process has been complicated
because it's been an argument over
presidential records but the justice
department believes that former
president trump might have committed a
crime or his associates in terms of
obstructing the collection of records in
the storage of records
bob you've done a lot of reporting on
trump's florida property over the years
and you mentioned a little of this in
your piece but what can you tell us what
more can you tell us about its security
and impossible vulnerabilities
based on our reporting part of the alarm
about mar-a-lago just across the water
here in palm beach florida is that this
is a club it's a club that's busy it has
a lot of people coming and going at
times foreign nationals
other politicians from around the world
business people and all them convene at
mar-a-lago to meet with former president
trump to have dinner and while it is
protected by the secret service there's
a concern that it's not fully protected
should someone with ill intentions ever
try to get in to that storage facility
that led to these red flags being raised
all right bob thank you for the report